let me ask you if you're on about the um
first part of the subtitle how climate
change Panic costs us trillions
how does climate change Panic cost us
trillions so we're basically deciding to
make policies that'll have fairly little
impact even in 50 or 100 years that
literally cost trillions of dollars so
you know give you two examples so uh the
European Union is trying to go to Net
Zero uh so our attempt to go halfway
there by 2030 uh will cost about a
trillion dollars a year uh and yet the
net impact will be almost unmeasurable
by the end of the century why is that
that's because the EU and the rich
countries there's a fairly small part of
the emissions that are going to come out
in the 21st century now we used to be a
big part of it that's mainly because
nobody else you know it was just the US
and and Europe and a few others that put
out CO2 in the in the 20th century so we
used to be big
but in the 21st century will be a small
bit player and so we're basically
spending a lot of money and remember a
trillion dollars is a lot of money that
could have been spent on a lot of things
that could have made you know Humanity
better on something that will only make
us a tiny bit better now it will do some
good
but you know the reasonable estimates is
if you do a cost benefit analysis and
again you know technically it's really
really complicated but the basic idea is
very very simple you just simply say
what are all the costs on one side and
what are all the benefits so the costs
are mainly that we have to live with
more expensive energy you have to forego
some opportunities you have to have you
know more complicated services that kind
of thing the benefit is that you cut
carbon emissions and that eventually
means that you'll have less climate
damage you'll have lower temperature
rises and so on if you try to weigh up
all those it's reasonable to assume that
the EU policies will deliver for every
dollar you spend it'll deliver less than
a dollar probably about 30 cents back on
the dollar which is a really bad way to
spend dollars because there's lots of
lots of other things out in the world
where you could do you know multiple you
know so for instance if you think about
tuberculosis or uh education of small
kids or nutrition for small kids and
those kinds of things every dollar you
spend will do like 30 to 100 worth of
good so they're much much better places
where you could spend this money
likewise uh the us is thinking of going
Net Zero by 20 50. it's not actually
going to happen but it's sort of a thing
that everybody talks about Biden is
talking a lot about it if you look at
the models that indicate how how how
much will that cost it's not impossible
that this will cost somewhere between
two and four trillion dollars per year
by mid-century and remember if the US
went carbon neutral today
by the end of the century that would
reduce temperatures by about 0.3 degree
Fahrenheit
so you would just be able to measure it
probably wouldn't in real life but you
know you'd just be able to measure it
again this is not saying that there's
not some good coming out of it but
you're basically spending an enormous
amount of money on fairly small benefits
so that's that's my main point yeah this
reminds me of what we were saying
earlier about um
the things that models don't integrate
and the things that cost benefit leave
out because you really can't go there
one of the issues facing the world right
now is the reality that we're reminded
of that energy availability is a
geopolitical
destabilizer if you have uneven access
to energy
and you have Vladimir Putin coming into
office or something else happening
that disrupts that system you're you're
vastly increasing poverty you this is
playing out across the world fertilizer
process fertilizer comes from gas
um natural gas
um if you can Envision a world later in
the century
where we no longer beholden on this
material in the ground at least fossil
fuels you know Cobalt and lithium for
batteries
that's pretty cool you know because
you're taking away geopolitical
instability and
you don't but that's not factored in
right that's like way outside of what
you'd factor in but it does feel like to
me you know if I was going to make the
case for
you can choose your trillions whatever
that investing big
isn't for these marginal things it's for
looking at the big picture of Worlds of
abundant energy that doesn't come from
from a black rock or a gooey liquid that
when you burn it creates but isn't that
what the proposals are is investing in
different kinds of energy renewable
energy so what is but I don't think most
people are making that case what's in
the in the trillion and the T costs
what's in corporate what are the big
costs there so the big cost is that you
have slightly lower productivity gains
so basically again yeah and this is sort
of the opposite of what we just talked
about by climate change we're we're
going to get richer and richer in the
world this is all models also the UN
this is really the only way that you can
get big climate changes because
everybody gets a lot richer so also the
developing world gets a lot richer so
we're likely to get richer but one of
the things that drive uh wealth
production is the fact that we have
ample and cheap and available energy if
you make that slightly harder which is
what you do with climate legislation
because you're basically telling people
you have to use a source of energy that
you would rather not have used had
because if people wanted to do it we'd
already have solved the problem so
you're basically telling me you've got
to use this wind turbine instead of this
uh natural gas plant or you know that
kind of thing it makes it's it's not
that you suddenly become poor or
anything it simply makes production
slightly harder what do you do when when
the wind is not blowing kind of thing
and of course we have lots of ways to
somewhat mitigate that but it's a little
more costly a little more complicated a
little less convenient and that means
you grow a little less that's the main
problem with with these policies that it
simply makes you somewhat less well-off
the energy becomes more inefficient yes